hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
cytoflex srt cell sorter what is it
really like for a user
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
labruz and brought to you by beckmann
culture life sciences
to learn more visit beckman.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
karen hogg
and dr peter o'toole from the university
of york
dr hogg and dr o'toole you may now begin
your presentations
okay i'm going on mute whenever you're
ready
jennifer thank you very much for that
very kind introduction and thank you
batman counter for actually inviting us
here today
to talk about the cytoflex srt and our
first-hand experiences of it
i'm peter o'toole from the university of
york bioscience technology facility and
joining me today
is dr karen hold karen would you like to
say hello hello
yes thank you for giving us the
opportunity to tell us our experiences
with the srt
and we're going to put it through its
paces as well so you'll get to see it
for real in action
karen thank you very much so before we
go any further i think we need to give a
quick disclaimer uh so because this is
sponsored by betterment culture however
and this is what they're trying to tell
you here dave is claiming to make sure
that whatever we say
can't be pinned back to them for any
liability reasons because what we are
going to tell you today is our own
personal
experiences and may not reflect uh the
views of batman culture themselves
so ben called thank you for trusting us
to actually present
oh you haven't seen what we've got to
say yet this
is going to be a very different type of
presentation
i have some slides that we'll go through
at the start
but then we are going to go live to the
instrument
we're going to set it up live and whilst
it's going through its protocols
we will come back to the slides and then
when karen goes pete
go live again we will go back to karen
and she'll go to the next
processes and we will hopefully
hopefully it is live it could go wrong
we will hopefully do a live cell sort
and
show you that it is sorting exactly what
it's telling us it's sorted
so we will talk you through it so this
is c to the panzer for us today
so you know it's really good just to so
you can understand exactly where we are
coming from
and what our interest is in the srt
itself
we're actually based in a
multi-disciplinary department of biology
which means we have to work with cancer
cells with the immunologists
with the stem cell groups with the
microbiologists
with their yeast their fungi the
bacteria
to the plant biologists with the grid
plant plus the biochemist
we even have to work with users outside
of the department chemists looking at
emotions
all sorts so when we look at
instrumentation especially in place
cytometers
we're looking for good usability and
good analysis
now on the right hand side with the
bioscience technology facilities so i'm
director of this facility
of which imaging and cytometry is just
one component of this
now imaging in cytometry is my own
personal lab
as well but karen hogg is i've got to
say
our resident expert in flow cytometry
uh read this itself and i've been
working with karen now
since 2002
uh if we go through the lab itself
is more than just a core facility for
the department of biology
we're an international hub for research
into neglected disease leash monies
when we have nodes in east africa south
asia and brazil
we're also a beta test and international
reference site for many
many leading international companies as
well as startup companies
for which the benchtop sorter the
cytoflex srt
is one such beta test and we've had this
since i think december was it karen
yeah that's an early christmas present
when it came in to york itself
uh but we haven't really had it up and
running because of kobe and christmas
through to the beginning start of this
year and i think you'll be blown away by
the amount of
data that we've already got off it from
a different user base
now this slide gives a brief overview
of our labs here at york
and in orange itself you can see where
the the research and development labs
are
and in blue is it's a service the core
the shared resource
labs themselves so this is where the
flow side thomases are i find this quite
interesting because when we started
we had an analyzer and a sorter in one
room
but as cytometry became very successful
at york
it grew in popularity and so we had
another one
and then another one and then
another one which kind of went into my
neighbor's room but i won't talk two
legs he's just next door
and then i had to start pinching space
into our r d labs
and then where kevin is sitting today in
our beauty test demo lab we have another
of our analyzers who's
encroached into that space and we have
the siteflex srt
in that space as well so it's amazing
just how much
flow cytometry has expanded in its
popularity
here at york and again back in 2002
when we started here at york we had just
a few instruments including the moflo
and the cyan and today we're really
blossoming
so many other technologies and in red
these are where we are international
reference sites or beta tests
for these various companies that you can
see here
now critically because we have to
serve a broad discipline of users
when we've run our analyzers we have to
make sure they can run with
all sorts of sampling types which is why
we have
varied systems and the mobile astros
which is ultimately
so versatile but that's not everything
and so really the srt is addressing a
real
need with us here at york now i've
stolen
some of the slides with permission from
batman culture
themselves because there seems to be
little point in reinventing the wheel
and just essentially using very similar
slides
so apologies between counter at this
point this is their picture of their
of their side flex srt in their lab and
you'll notice a little post-it note
on the side of it this is it in
our lab here in york and we will be
going live to the camera in just a
moment's time
i'd like to point out you'll notice the
two flowers this is when it arrived at
the end of december
two pots of flowers because actually
arrived pretty much on karen's birthday
so kevin didn't just get flowers from uh
from ourselves but she also got an srt
to start playing with
so on this point i think you should see
it live in the lab so karen
over to you
thank you very much pete before i
actually run a sample i'm just going to
open the door and show you where the
collection of the samples will take
place
either in tube or in plate mode and also
where the sample is loaded
into the cytoflex srt so i'm going to
take out the sample
tube this has got some quality control
beads in
and place it back into the sample holder
and shut the door and also close the
collection
door but also show you that there's um
some lights
to enable you to see with inside
as well without having to open the door
i'm now going to
share my screen and take you to the
application software which is the site
expert srt
software so you can see the quality
control
actually being run so previous to this
there's a startup program which takes 10
minutes
and the fluidics are checked the
pressurized tanks
are verified to make sure they've got
the right pressure
and the flow cell and the sheath filter
is the
bubbles now the quality control beads
are the cytoflex
daily qc fluorosphere so anybody that's
used to
having a cytoflex analyzer they're
exactly the same b
so we have to choose the qc beads lot
number because the target gains are lot
specific
so i'm going to click start now and the
qc
will commence and the sample will
then the chamber will be pressurized so
you'll see
that happening in the window if you keep
an eye on that but right now i'm going
to pass you back to pete and it's more
going to walk you a bit
further through the um what's in the box
and the lasers
and the detectors that we have within
their system
so overdue p yeah thank you karen and if
i could grab my camera back on please
thank you very much karen that's great
thank you
so actually why is it qc even
so this is quite a good time to bring
this this is the
option laser configurations for this now
at the beta test stage actually there
was a few of us brought
in at the concept stage of this product
and i was fortunate to be feeding into
the concept stage
and what we what what was originally
designed we actually came up
as a user group of users real users uh
that gave some suggestions to contact
and actually they adopted quite a few of
those
i think that's fantastic it means they
have made a product not what
engineers think is great but they've
listened to the user base
and put in what the users were
requesting and thought were best
so you can see here the the various
options of the colors and if you look at
this topic
this is the one that excites me most is
this top option is we now got five
colors off the violet
which is brilliant for using the bv dies
as well as other
flora chrome types so this is not a
system
that is just for cytoflex users this is
a system that our four tessa users
can come in and use without having to
adapt their panel significantly
and that's really important that it
doesn't matter if they're the cyan users
the cytoflex users for testing users
they can come straight on most of them
can apply the same panels
into the srt for sorting their cells so
we've got five off the violet
critically five off the yellow where we
get the best signal to noise
for most of these emissions we've got
three off the red and two off the 488
nanometer laser but of course not
everyone needs
all those colors and those colors come
with extent of course
until you can cut right down to much
more cut down paired back
options to make it a very affordable
option for those who are just looking
for something more simple
for their analysis itself
so you've got those two to four lasers
up to 15 colors throughout that time and
upgradable through its lifetime which is
also quite important
to remember and kevin have i missed
anything critical
about this these configurations that
you'd like to add
no i think you've covered most of it but
its flexibility and its range has really
allowed people to move quite seamlessly
from their site flex analyzers onto the
sorters so
um that's been really good when people
have got a panel that they want to
you know have a go with a sorter it's
been brilliant because i've just been
able to say well come along let's just
give it a go i've not really had to
do much amendments or tweaking or ask
them to find a different antibody slur
for and and we did mention earlier that
the need to do all sorts of side
particles and it has got that
violent side scatter detector on here
again for
enhancing small particle detection
so it is a cuvette base sort of this is
different to our astronauts it won't
replace our astronauts it fits in a very
different niche
area maybe actually probably more varied
areas compared to our astronauts
and we'll tell you the real advantages
of it in just a little bit compared to
that
but we've got a fixed laser alignment so
there's no no tweaking of the lasers
this is
this the root cavern's in the room that
kevin's in at the moment
doesn't have air conditioning uh if it
has some crude heating
it's not an optimal lab environment and
yet it's still working
super reliably that's really critical
with that fixed alignment is very very
robust
we've talked about the laser line the
sensitivity is because it's using the
same apd's
uh as the cytoflex does which really do
make a significant signal to noise
difference which is great for heating
out those small
detectors itself so
you can see the peak we've got the
scatter sensitivity and so forth
on this as well if i just flick to the
next slide
another really important difference so
again
this is a titanflex but it isn't a
a peristaltic pump analog like the
analyzer
this is now as karen mentioned this is a
pressurized system
just like a classic sorter would be
so we've got our sheath pressure so it's
got that whole fluidic systems of that
it's quite a small footprint it can be
on benchtop it can be under the desk
which gives more flexibility for space
so it is a incredibly small footprint so
i think you saw that when cameron moved
your arm across earlier and you'll see
more of that later
when i go in there to get the live sort
offer to show you what it's actually
sorted
okay so it is neat and tidy and small
karen's already mentioned that she's put
the five mil tube
into the set so it's a classic five mil
tube that you'd introduce your sample
into the sorter itself and it can really
have various flow rates from around 10
to around 100 microliters per minute
approximately it is adjustable obviously
and it can be really ramped up
especially for cleaning
uh the nozzle size the nozzle is a bit
different we'll come to the nozzle i
think kevin will show you that later on
once we've done the source
camera will take the nozzle out and show
you it physically it's a very different
type of nozzle
to look at and super easy to use which
is a real bonus again
for users who will be using this
themselves
so we've got that it's a fixed nozzle
100 microns
four-way sorting itself and it can
sort your fuel and it can catch the
aborts
as well so you can still maximize your
yield
on the back of this now one of the other
bits that we were really keen
to emphasize that they put the the
high-end
robotic arm inside the chamber which can
do your 96 384 well plate
sorting so if you're for your stem cell
research and so forth
or for your generating your cell genomic
analysis
but here's the key thing it now doesn't
do two points
positioning and extrapolate through to
all 96 wells
it now does four point uh
checked controls so now it doesn't
matter if the robotic arm isn't perfect
for whatever mechanical reason
it will be able to extrapolate to make
sure that it's always hitting the middle
of every well across the whole
plate which actually makes it far more
robust
and far fewer engineer call-outs and for
us it's just so much easier and more
reliable
compared to other systems that we've had
in the past
so what we'll show you in a little while
not quite yet
is we'll show you actually how we set up
a plate source
now most of our users do bulk sorting
but it's very hard to show you that the
bulk sort has been really
really good in quick time but what we'll
do is a plate sort
and when we do the plate saw we'll be
able to take the plate live
take it to a microscope and show you
that it is sorted every event that it is
said it will sort
so i'm going to hand you back to karen
who i think is now ready for the next
stage karen
yes indeed so i'll bring you back to the
site expert
software
finished so we've had some
checks done on the system to make sure
that the laser output
is within specifications and the target
gain fluorescence intensity and the
coefficient of variance the cv
is all within specifications now this
part of the qc
also does um first part of the drop
delay
which is the distance from the bottom of
the cuvette
to a maintenance six three eight
nanometer laser
and that's um what the drop delay one
determination
is shown there but now that's been
completed
we want to set the sorter up for sorting
so it does a sort calibration and it's
asking me now do i want to start this
right away and i'm going to click yes
and so
now it brings up a window to
do the droplet calibration and also do
the side
stream calibration and finish that drop
delay
calculation so i'm going to pass you
back to pete so that he can finish off
talking about the soft
system while this five minutes and 48
and counting down
seconds carries on so back to you pete
and then we can come back when this
has completed its task thank you karen
if i just bring my camera back on
thank you very much i'm back
uh so we will look at the plate sorting
in more detail
in a few moments and we'll show you how
we calibrate across all four
points but actually karen do you want to
talk about some of this as well because
this is just a cytoflex uh software so
site expert software
so actually if you do have a cytoflex
already
it's exactly the same software platform
just with a few added bits
such as being able to see the stream
live as you're sorting even though
you can't do much with it it sorts it
all out for you in the background
but it does make it super intuitive for
the users
so at york we have been getting users to
use it themselves to make sure that it's
not just experts that can use it but the
sort of
the the users can pick it up really
easily
and we'll have to more talk about that
more and uh try and bring more about
that into it
so karen do you want to just talk
through these extra bits
fancy and yes indeed all of our users
have found the workflow for startup
qc and drop delay calibration really
easy to follow as the
processes is very intuitive so the sort
calibration
is now complete so we can move over to
the software again
and then get sorting so i'm going to
share my screen and hopefully then you
will be able to see
everything that is going on now i just
also want to point that while pete was
talking
my microphone dropped out so i'm now
using the microphone
on the um webcam so my voice might sound
a bit different and also you might
actually hear
the noise from the spikes srt a little
more than you did before
because it sat directly on top
so now i'm sharing my screen you should
be able to see the qc report
and the thought status window showing us
that the drop delay
calibration has been run and it has
passed
and that the auto maintain status
is is on so now that is complete i can
show fewer details of that so that we
can actually
get the experiment running so the
drop delay is shown by the green line
and then this
red line you can actually move to
wherever your preference
is so today i'm going to mark the little
satellite drop between the last
patch drop and the first free drop just
so i can keep track of where that
is so now i'm going to close the qc
because we're all done with that
and we are we are ready to play and i'm
going to open
from this window here which gives you a
list of recent experiments
the gst thought that i'm going to do
today
now i've already run this sample a
little bit so it enables me to
to set the gate but i'm going to
duplicate
the tube without data give me an empty
tube here
and then i'm going to click run and we
should then see cells
through to the slow cell and then the
signals arriving at the detector
so we've got our forward arm side
scatter shown here
we've got our single cells that are
identified by size scatter height versus
area
and then we have our gfc corrections
shown
here so the acquisition settings can be
changed
during a run mode sample by clicking
this icon here there's a little spanner
shown there
and we can change any of the parameters
so here i'm just going to change the
forward scatter down
and then click restart and you can see
that hopefully the cells have
shifted in that plot if i want to change
the plot type i'm just going to change
it to a dot block
it might make it easier for you to see
on the screen it's very easy you can
just right click
and then choose the type of top that you
that you require
so i'm going to close this acquisition
window now
and if i want to record the sample i can
just click record and now it changes
the blue flashing dot to a green
flashing dot
you still get an sps file if you use a
run
file there is no problem with that so
don't fear if you forgot to get press
record you still get your data which is
always a bonus and so what we want to do
now
is consider our gate and whether um we
are we are happy to
um set them up for 40. so i'm going to
stop
this run now and then
set this up for first for sorting so i'm
going to duplicate the tube again
and click run and this time i'm going to
bring
up my store plate and you can change
um the parameters that you wish to
have sorted into your 96 well place
before we do the sorting you need to
make sure that the
sort squirts are going to go into the
right well so we need to do
some some calibration so i'm going to do
that next by clicking the calibrate tool
so you've got a little play
icon there and we can see that we've got
a standard 96 volt plate and then we've
got four corners to calibrate which
gives you
really good deposition of yourself into
the world
across the whole of your plate many of
our users have been very impressed with
the
accuracy of this to all parts of the
plate
so you can choose to test a current well
so here is upper left
upper right lower right or lower left
or i am going to choose all corners
and then choose to test
now um we then get work in the four
corners of the plate and you can then
say whether it needs to go off a bit
down a bit left it right a bit
and then you can then save those
positions and then you're
good for sorting so i'm just going to
let it complete that task
and then visibly have a look to make
sure that we're going to get the right
cells
in the right well so i'm going to open
the door
and have a look and certainly
yes that looks good so we're now
ready to sort
so i can save this
if i want to sort a different number of
cells in the world so here i've got
20 in these wells and 10 in the
blue well then i need to be able to
tell it to do that so i've just clicked
um a new tube
and i'm going to highlight these wells
tell them
that they are going to have a hundred
cells in these ones so i've given that
group the name of a hundred
i'm going to choose purity mode here so
you have various different options
single 312 or indeed
enriched and then i'm going to have the
target count for 100 so it matches the
sort group name
we should see we've got a different
color and hundreds shown there
so i'm now happy
that we have got our thoughts set up
correctly
and we've got our logic set up for gst
and that's shown in the hierarchy here
we've got cells
single cells and gst so
we're now good to go but so you can
actually
see that happening i'm going to now
switch my camera over so that you can
actually
visibly see the sort taking place
in front of the cytoflex so if i open
the window we can see we've got the
plate
in place there and so if i um
shut the door hopefully you can still
see with the light on and
now i can set it up to actually sort
so if i press sort it will immediately
go to that task i need to put my auto
maintain
on and then we can
proceed further so the order to maintain
is just making sure the drop delay is
in the correct place and then we can
continue sorting
so if i click sort now off it will go
and put those cells in the world as
requested
so we've got 100 cells going into a
one to six and then dropping down the
plate and quite swiftly moving on to the
tens and twenties
we thought target percentage is 63 so
we've chosen something fairly fast today
um we're not looking for something
that's a very very rare percentage so
this part will be done swiftly
so at this point hopefully peter's gonna
appear as if by magic
and take the plate over
to the comfortable microscope so we can
visually show you
the number of gst positive
cells in the well so um
i'll just wait for him to appear
so there you go so you've got plenty
a little bit of feedback there as we're
both in the room but hopefully
you'll excuse us but in this live demo
the pete's rushed off to the confocal
microscope
to have a look and count the number of
fluorescent cells and hopefully prove to
you
fingers crossed so there are 20 gfp
positive cells
um in the wells shown um
in this part of the place and 10 in
those i don't think we're going to go as
far as counting the hundreds because we
might be here to speak on
[Music]
so while he's actually doing that
i can duplicate this tube and show you
how to set
up a bulk sport so i just duplicated the
two
and now i can um
show you how to do that so if i close my
saw
plate window and then we can
do a full sort
set up and it's saying i'm gonna lose my
plate settings
if i continue i will click yes because
i'm quite happy to do that for this for
this demo
so here we've got left two left one
right one and right
two so if i want to then sort
i can activate the string that i want
i can choose the logic and i can choose
the
purity mode so the vault sort
single purity or enrich
so we can take the target count
the tube size as shown there is five mil
and you can see
how much volume you might put into the
tube to start with and it will monitor
the thought to make sure you don't
overflow so i think i can stop
sharing now and pete will
hopefully be able to tell us how many
years
coming to it nothing like a bit of
pressure is there
right i need you to be able to see them
right here
yeah i can see that all right i've got
the first drop
bingo oh
just stop let's be opposed i can see one
two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve
14 15 16 17 18 19
20 bear with me and i will go and get
the
next well on top of that as well give it
a second
oh i have a lot of microscopy kills
karen
oh you can use the microscope pete i'm
sure you can remember
go for it i've got one two three four
five six seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14
16 16 17 18
19 and 20 and do one more
be adventurous
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten seven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen seventeen eighteen
nineteen
twenty oh sorry i didn't show it today
there you go do it again sorry one two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19
20. brilliant
and i know it is getting nicely
on the confocal and
brilliantly i don't think i have
disturbed if i just stick my camera back
round
aha yep the grass has been quite nicely
so i've even got another witness beside
the live one
that's on the alive at seven karen back
over to you
thank you very much pete
so i'm going to share my screen again
and finish showing you the
bolt sorting setup while he then gets uh
back to the office to continue on with
the presentation
so i was mentioning that the um bolt
stream
bolt sorting allows you to type in
the volume that you put into your
5 mil tube and then it will show you the
total volume in a bar
at the bottom here so i might as well
carry on and
sort this um and we can
then see how it looks in progress
while uh while that's going on so i'm
going to choose some
stop criteria here so i'm just going to
choose
100 000 events and time slot well
we can just leave it to runs if i i'm
going to sit with it i'm not going to
let it
overrun but if you want it to sort for
10 minutes and stop you could
plug that in there so
i can now click sort and it will sort
away
and we will then see the numbers appear
on the screen
so we can see that it has got a thought
count now
that is that is going up and we can see
the events per second
here is only showing at about 140 but
the sample flow rate is 10
microliters a minute so i can take that
up to
60 microliters a minute and we can now
see that the events per second
have increased and the thought count is
is succeeding
um so it will give you a message if your
abort rate
goes higher and red these numbers will
appear and that's useful particularly
for users
that are not familiar with sorting it
gives them a warning that maybe they
might want to
consider their parameters to to get a
better yield
um so also during the sport if the
cytoflex srt identifies any problems
um it will stop the sort the waste
catcher will come out
the flow cell will de-bubble and then if
the
um system is able to then continue
sourcing
it it will continue to do so and this is
important
for users that um have left
the system um and then if there's some
minor problems
the just the sorter can correct them
itself and and then
carry on the sport um and
certainly you know this gives the users
that um
confidence that they can do self-service
sorting on and walk up and proceed
um with their system and there are
certain checks and balances in place
to alert them if there's a problem to
try and make some corrections and then
tell them if
it's not possible and you need to
intervene
so i think pete is back
now and is going to continue on with the
presentation
of the system um and um so i will
stop sharing my screen for now but i'll
let the thought carry on going
um and maybe we can pop back and see how
it's going so you can see how it how it
looks
so back over to you pete
thank you very much and oh my goodness
we did it live
brilliant sorry i'm still buzzing
that that's one hell of a risk that's
absolutely brilliant well done karen
you're a genius uh always the srt your
genius or maybe a bit of both
karen thank you that was brilliant in
action
okay so actually hopefully you grabbed
from that
that you've watched it go through qc
you've watched it
go through and kevin had already
calibrated the play earlier and
it's a 96 volt plate it's going to take
a lot to miss that but we've done this
in 384 as well
and critically it was easy it was really
super simple you've watched the whole
process
live if you if you ever buy one of these
and you don't know how to do it just
watch this back and you can see how to
do it
you've almost got a tutorial and that's
really critical so if we come back to
the slides that we had
it does all of these aspects
automatically it really takes very
little
to actually carry it's not your genius
it's just the instrument because it
is so intuitive and does so much for you
in this case
cam has just talked you through the auto
recovery the sort rescue
the fact we can sort of bought some
non-abort and how easy it has been to
set up
we had these in our back pocket just in
case
it didn't work but thankfully everything
is performing just as we had anticipated
but you can just never be sure
kevin i can't remember because i've been
in the other room did you talk about the
sort reports
they can look at your purity you can
look at your yield you can look at the
number of cells
you can fix it just as you would with
any cell source you have
all the same capabilities they have
looked at what the mo
flow the legacy that they've
astros all those things and they've
imported a lot of that into this
so they've kind of made a hybrid of what
works really well
and they're miniaturized and what what's
the best of the side effects that
sensitivity the user friendliness and
everything else to that platform
so the sort reports can be very detailed
it can show you everything
and the user everything that they would
need to do but you know what
you've seen it work and we did the 96
mile plate so we could count
20 cells and these weren't beads please
let me just stress in case you missed it
these were cells not these
okay so there were gfp tag cells that we
were sorting
and you can see if you can sort 20 if
you ask it to sort 20 000
is gonna sort 20 000 and it just show
it's the quickest way to show
that's the case so obviously for bulk
source it's equally
relevant so maybe now it'd be really
good time
to get that one that's that's a maybe
it's really good
now to actually to to walk you through
some user examples
and actually dave kent's lab have been
awesome in supporting this
and you know they're one of our big
users on the astros
at one and have actually been coming in
and using the swords themselves
and being able to prove that this isn't
just applicable for
those nice gfp cells but for quite
awkward cell types as well and hemostat
hemoplastic stem cells are not the
easiest to work with
and they've been doing single cell uh
glass sorting and look at colony
formations because you know what
kevin it's not me the expert here this
is now
karen and all the hard work she put in
with the astros to get this set up
and then just rolls it over on the srt
overnight so karen would you like to
pick up from here you just tell me when
to change slides it's easier
so if you move over to the to the next
slide the first thing we did with the
the fireflies srt was sorted speed but
we moved on for that
pretty quickly because it just went over
that hurdle almost like
stepping stepping off the curve so we'll
move on to the to the next slide
and we've just shown you this in terms
of seeing is really believing but the
next
challenge was to do um gfp
positive cells um into different worlds
at different number of targets
and we went down to um one cell per well
because the single cell sorting
that's what you need to know and and i
don't know how well
this came out in this slide but if you
go back to the previous slide i don't
know if that's possible pete
but you can just see there's a little
picture of ducks in a row
on that bottom slide that's just the way
the short droplet came out and i do
really like all my ducks to be in a row
so i i
quite laughed when i saw that under the
microscope
so so the next slide shows a little bit
more detail of um
where in the well the disposition is and
we can see
that there was only one drop in the well
and thanks to
um grant and graham in the lab for
helping me uh
get this big pile image on the on the
confocal so
it was their idea to do that so credit
where credit's due
but again you can see it's uh nicely
placed in the well
and then the next slide shows the actual
fluorescence data
of this now this is a stem cell
panel um and it's an eastland for any of
you that
know the terminology and this is david
kent's group
go to panel if you want to check a
sorter out and particularly single cell
cloning
so we're looking for quite a rare
population there it's typically
0.01 or lower and nicely within the
software it allows you to emphasize the
rare events
and they're shown in blobs of pink on
the screen so
hopefully that that is visible and
they're the cells that we were sorting
into single wells and then culturing for
a week
in 96 well plates and the next slide
shows the um output of that and and juan
the postdoc in the lab actually did the
imaging for this so it was not
biased i didn't do it although i was
desperately wanting it to work i put it
into his hands
and and amazingly 93 of the wells out of
96
had colonies in at um day seven post
sorting so that's you know 90
96 survival and if they can do that
with single cell sorting and stem cells
basically you know
it can do anything and so we've got a
movie
of the 96 well plate images
and then i've just done start and stop
randomly throughout the movie
to see if i can find one of those few
wells that didn't have a colony in and
um
i didn't but we'll uh now show you that
and um see what happens yeah so so
because of how we've had to do this we
actually recorded this in advance
because
what you're seeing is a different
platform to how we're seeing what you're
seeing right now different to what we're
seeing right now
uh so we've had to pre-record this but
it is just random
pausing of this movie to show what
happens so
yeah watch it 96 world play colonies
play
stop play
so fly
so the key thing here karen that you're
showing is there was 96 wells
all were put through into a movie stack
so you can see that each well
had colonies forming now some of those
colonies looked a bit different and
karen can explain why
that is in just a moment but the random
stopping was just to kind of show you
that doesn't matter where you stop
you're going to find cells and these are
all from
single cell to start with so karen back
over to you
oh karen i think i've lost your
microphone again maybe it wasn't the
microphone before
that's uh actually while cam is just
playing with her microphone i
i will add live a bit from here
all right so this is where i
was strong so these cells will go on and
they will actually differentiate
differently from those colonial stem
cells to start with
and you do see different colonies
forming which is why
you see those differences go through it
so karen i think you may be okay now
okay so
hopefully now we can go through some of
the user
data that we're um have used on this
cycle flight srt in the short time that
we've had it
so um the islam colonies that that we've
seen was was great to do because it was
a rare cell
and a bit of a challenge but absolutely
got over that hurdle which i was really
pleased about
um so these um next slide just gives you
a flavor of some of the the sorting that
we've done and we've seen this live so
we can skip over this
because we've actually um done done this
sort
but the purity is shown on this slide
here
and um i can't actually read the
percentage because pete's in front of
the slide but i think it's 98 or 99
pure on that screen for a bulk sort
for gfp sorting which is important
because um
obviously we want the furious to be as
good as it can be
so the next slide on from
that um shows um
how to operate the the sword and and set
the
set the sport up for a plate sourcing
which is shown in their next slide and
again
we've seen that for real going through
the software and highlighting the cells
dictating the logic and saying how many
cells of a particular type
you want them to be in in particular
well in the place
so the next slide on from that then
shows some
some bolt sorting and some plate sorting
so the slide on um again is
the east slam the data that we showed
with the rare cells shown
in pink so this is the sort logic we
showed previously
and then the next couple of slides is
showing the plate format so we can quite
swiftly move
so though because we've we've shown that
set up live but this
was the plate that we used for the for
the east lab
and then because we wanted to make sure
that the um purity was good
we actually took one of the populations
and did a bulk
sort which is what you can see on the
screen now
and then ran through some pbs
just to make sure the lines were clean
before doing some post-sort analysis
which is the next slide and we can see
that the
purity of the sorted cells was very good
and you know this is a bone marrow
threat so it's
quite a heterogeneous cell population
and many different colours and we can
see there that the sorter has nicely
with
good purity kicks out the the correct
cells and it's the
far right plot in the second row down
that i've taken as their post
or purity gate and again it's 98 or 99
positive i can't see from here p
yeah no i can't see them by the camera
but also notice we haven't changed the
sort box
and actually you can see that some have
just lost a bit of fluorescence
intensity and actually if you widen that
the purity be even better than it is i
don't think it's mixing
populations it is just the sort usually
when you post analyze you'll increase
that sort box a bit just to allow for a
bit of movement
within that population upon re-analysis
which you're not seeing here
yeah which is why i've got an extra plot
and you get a normal distribution off
the thought gate which is uh what's
shown there
so then going on from that looking at a
different sample type
um so this is now a primary mouse cells
and
is bolt sourcing for genomic analysis so
sorting um directly into um trisol
so this is um cells from from mouth
thymus
and so we've got b and t cells
delineated by various different markers
there and then if we go through to the
next
slide we can see
the the full panel for the sourcing with
more cells in the gate
and then further on from that we can see
after um back flushing the system
um after the sort that it was clean but
here
if you go back aside pete actually sorry
oh sorry kevin sorry kevin
um no it's my fault um um we can see as
i showed earlier the green bars
showing um how the sort is progressing
and the volume in the in the tubes as
well so it gives you a visualization
of how how full you choose the guessing
so the the next slide again shows you
that the system is is clean after
backswishing and enables you to do a
postcard
so clearly to show the good purity again
with a different type of cell
um through the system and um yeah
99 98 purity i think it's 99 in that one
i should have written these numbers down
apologies for not being able to have
them for hand
and this was um a bold sort of different
direction
so this is the other stream post-war
data
shown there so um we've also sorted
diatoms on the sorter recently which was
quite good fun to do and that worked
beautifully well but i am waiting the
results of those
to see how um how they are growing
um but single cell sorting diaphragms
with uh
with our our next thing that we've we've
done on here which was good fun to do
and
uh nice imaging as well but we'll report
on that another time
and thank you and hopefully
you've just seen the system live in
action
uh i think that's so much better than
just hearing us talk about how good is
it because we could say anything but
actually seeing it in action
hopefully shows you just how easy you
know within that hour we've done a whole
sort we've done
actually a 96 volt plate sort we've
shown that it's worked
all whilst presenting all about the
system
itself and i think that gives us a lot
of confidence
and our users that are using it
themselves uh
i think that's the mind-blowing thing is
that they can come in and within an hour
within one hour they can be
self-sufficient and sorting on this
that's all the training they need
if they're familiar with a site to flex
to start with
so just before we end i'm gonna be
cheeky there's a podcast series called
the microscopist
which has been really successful and
it's not just microscopic
it's also it doesn't matter what you do
it's really interesting to get to know
the person's up close
and personal but coming soon is flow
stars
okay so this is introducing all sorts of
people including
karen herself and eric davis
and a load of other people so you've got
the isaac president johnny moore the
incoming
isaac president rachel errington alfonzo
blanco surely you must know alfonso tim
bushnell
i mean from the clinical world liam
whitby paul robinson one of the pioneers
of flow cytometry paul smith an ex
president of isaac it's not just about
play cytometry
get to know why they're interested in it
their careers their fascinating stories
but also what they get up to outside of
work how do they balance work life
it's brilliant amazing to sit down with
a cup of coffee and it's like you're
chatting too much
so have a watch at some of those finally
a quick thanks from karen
and myself to all the people who have
inputted into so
many much of this work that you've seen
today it doesn't just happen by magic
and all the data and everything
it's actually i've left one teaser for
you because karen is now getting ready
to shut the instrument down
we want to go back to karen just to show
you the nozzle
itself so karen can you switch cameras
please and go and have a look at the
nozzle
yeah thank you pete school boy era so i
can now um
show from the camera view the the
nozzles i've just taken it
out of the system so i will just switch
cameras
and so i've taken the nozzle
out of the system so i'll put it back
into place
actually to show you how it's removed so
this
illumination chamber door opens here and
then i can press these two
clamps and take the nozzle out and the
nozzle is situated
here where my finger is and this is the
nozzle holder here so that is the
the bit that does a lot of the work
within the
within the 5 flex srt and that's where
it's located
within the system very conveniently it
has the word up
on it so when you're inserting it into
the system the software
tells you gives you a nice little
picture but you just push it
into the water there and then close the
illumination window and that is the
nozzle
ready to go you visually check the
nozzle before you put it into the sorter
just to make sure the aperture is clear
and that has all you need to do
so that's the last thing i wanted to to
just show you before we uh
finish the presentation on how easy it
is to work karen thank you very much you
might want to switch your camera back
around
i i just pushed actually the slide back
where you could see the nozzle just on
the side
and karen just there so
one final thank you actually i thank
culture and jennifer for introducing the
start and court for inviting us to do
this karen
you have been a superstar and you're so
brave to take this on
and do it live and set it up thank you
so much for being
a perfect member of the lab and such a
example exemplar for any flow
cytometry's out there so actually karen
publicly
thank you very much for being part of
our team here no
thank you and thank you to batman
courses for spreading a wonderful
instrument that
generally is just fantastic and you can
just walk up
and sport and many of the users have
been amazed at the
way in which the workflow and the
robustness of being able to do that
is and the team here at imaging and
psychometry have been fantastic helping
put it through his paces and help me and
the users um
yeah get everything as it should be
so thank you for everybody let's go cute
we were
going to run out of time for questions
aren't we so
jennifer do we have any questions yes we
do thank you
dr hogg and dr o'toole for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
how many users themselves have used it
i think it's six or seven but karen do
you wanna actually just rattle off their
names
because they they need credit for being
so good at beta testing this as well
yeah so we've got um
juan alyssa dan brian
and we have ian and
phil yeah and also yes
so and grace yeah it's seven
seven i think seven or eight yeah seven
and a half
there you go these are people who can
use the sorter
the the flex srt themselves and that's
only since
we've really only been engaging them
since february once we got completely
comfortable with it everything else
so actually it's you know not very long
at all
and actually i've got a user books on it
at eight o'clock tonight
and i'm not gonna be here
great well thank you so much for those
answers okay we've got another question
uh how loud is it so
karen has actually the microphone is on
top
of it uh so not very loud at all
which is really good certainly quieter
than any sorter that we've had in the
past
i can certainly hear myself
well that's think we can't hit yes so
yeah
if it's if there's any vibrations it's
in a small room as you saw when i went
and got the place
uh but yeah it's i can't hear it from
it's just literally behind that wall and
i can't hear it
perfect another question can the samples
be
chilled um yes there
is a report in the sample collection arm
plate
for a chiller so if you wanted them to
be maintained
room temperature or below to four then
yeah that would be possible
yes i don't have that setup here on the
beetle system but
it is certainly okay
yeah pretty classic system for it
compared to uh it's very similar to what
the astronaut has for that
okay thank you and our next question
here
what tube types can it sort into
um so the the tube type that it can
source into so you've got the 5 mil
flow tubes or 15 mil collection tubes
but i have also taken 1.5 mil eppendorfs
as well
and put them on top of the five mils
both tubes to sort into as well so
there is um other options as well with
um
sorting into additional tubes with a
little bit of creativity
and what tube types can be used for the
starting samples
for the input samples is yeah yeah
so the input samples are at the standard
five mil
difficulty tube
okay great and here's our next question
uh have you tried
index sorting did we not show that
yeah i don't think i showed that button
so yes index sorting is on by default so
you don't have to remember to turn it on
and for all plate sourcing index
sourcing is there should you
um wish it and you have to act actively
uncheck it if you don't want it
so that's a good way around that movie
that you saw where all those well
started from oneself that was all index
sorted
it's imperative to their research they
want to know exactly where within the
population their cells were coming from
so that was an index source sorry we
just must have missed that slide
that's why we do the q a right and we've
got one
more question here have you attempted to
run it dry
well well i'd like to say on purpose or
accidentally on purpose
yes i have been sorting and
then um been distracted
and left the sorter and there is a
button on the sorter that tells you how
many hours of scoring you have left
so you know you you get some perception
of time um but i did walk away
and it did then stop itself because it
went too low and i was
very curious to see um if there was
still
solution above the inlet valve and there
was so there was no air in the system
it worked perfectly for rescuing
um the sort of status so all i had to do
is just top it up with chief start it up
again and
it was a dream so i was very grateful
of that yeah i think that's really
important that's a
really important question and i think it
really rounds up the whole package
that this is a system that's great karen
said we've got a user coming in tonight
at eight o'clock
to use it themselves and you've got to
have trust in your users
and for a high-end sorter quite often
that's quite difficult to do and this
has the sensitivity the speed
the capabilities of high-end sorter but
it's actually on a on a
really super user-friendly platform that
actually we can trust them to use
so we know they're not going to break it
we also know they're not going to be
calling us at 10 or 11 o'clock tonight
to put things right for them because
it kind of protects the user it's not
only user friendly but it protects the
user as well
so they can be confident in using it i
can't stress how important that is
yeah there's bench top sorters but to be
truly walk up and use it
we would i i can't say an hour's
uh training that right kate is and i was
training that's all i wanted
but for me and to be able to be
self-sufficient it's just
mind-blowing from my perspective i've
just not seen that before
and then the users need to be confident
that they're getting the right sales is
the right purity in the right place
because the downstream worse is
expensive in time and cost of money for
reagents
so you know they wouldn't do it if they
didn't have absolute confidence in the
sort
and their capabilities with it without
me presence so
you know that's that's credit to the
sorter under themselves to put that
knowledge together to do that
well yeah and the trainer karen so
credit to yourself as well thank you
again dr hogg and dr
o'toole for your time today and for your
important research
we would also um well do you have any
final comments before we go
actually dr hogg and dr o'toole
well i just want to say thank you to
betterment culture and celebrities and
to yourself
for allowing us to present our insights
at decidedlex srt today
it's been really good fun to work with
and show people
how it operates and put it through its
places and to see their reaction to it
as well and
you know they get genuine pleasure about
being able to do this self-service
sorting
so um it's you know it's been it's been
really nice to be part of that
so yeah thank you and you know it'd be
great to get some feedback to what
people thought about seeing it live
because it is a very different way of
doing this it's not a dry presentation
hopefully people felt as though they
were in the room in the lab watching it
for some of it's
uh in a real lab uh with a real mic
real cytometer real microscope and and
i think we're real aren't we real people
so but yeah so
actually thanks to the audience for
putting up for what was quite a bit
jumped about a bit because we were
showing it live so thank you
well thank you both again uh for being
with us today and for sharing your
research
and we would like to thank um lab roots
and our sponsor beckman culture for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speakers
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye